I had the time of my life making this
movie and part of that is what Star Wars
you know means to me and I think means
means to a lot of us and a lot of that
as all the people I got to work with the
incredible crew the amazing folks at
Disney at Lucasfilm and the incredible
cast just like my favorite people and
we've got a few of them here today
you better have yeah so we got some
familiar faces for you I'm going to
start out by welcoming Daisy Ridley
[Applause]
next let's welcome to the stage spin
himself John boyega Wendell and Christi
is in the house captain phasma Kelly
Marie Tran who plays Rose in the phone
[Applause]
laura dern is here with us last but
certainly not least we have Benicio del
Toro in a star wars movie let's welcome
Mark Hamill up to the stage
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
when I read the script there were so
many unexpected elements which is great
in the Star Wars film because it's
getting harder and harder to bring new
things to the table and this is a real
game changer we wanted to give you guys
a look inside kind of what we've been
doing the past few years and this thing
is it's it's super cool I think we
should go ahead and run it this is a
really lovely behind-the-scenes piece
he'll show you a little bit about the
last Jedi everybody stop Episode eight
gosh the first film didn't even have a
number
Ryan has written a story that unexpected
but right some of the stuff that
happened people have not oh my god
even though I think I know it all they
throw things at least story wise I never
could have imagined and even though
everybody knows it's the second in a
trilogy it feels like it's own thing
Star Wars is so cool because there's all
these creatures probably amazing visual
effects
like all the characters are also so
complex
why and least organs will keep out ah
new director colleague mr. Lerner which
is
[Music]
it feels like the storylines became more
established we're really getting to know
these new characters also with the
characters that we know and love
within their lives change
everything that being shifted in the
opposite way so what we were disinfected
up to seven bridesmaids star was fresh
in you
I'm hoping it'll be a little shopping
but I'm hoping it'll feel real and
honest
the most ancient story of it against
evil
toes in the most fascinating way but
it's not a real spirit result today
it's about family and that's what's so
powerful about it
[Applause]
you